today I'm attempting to get the platinum
trophy for Lego Harry Potter years one
through four on the PS4 there's just one
problem this game is notoriously glitchy
when it comes to Trophies actually
Platinum the original release on PS3 all
the way back in 2011 but it actually
took a very politely written email to WB
support basically pleading for a patch
to make it happen because there was one
single character that I couldn't unlock
Dumbledore nah Voldemort nope it was a
character simply referred to as Roy why
kid you not Roy fortunately it was
eventually patched and I was able to
secure my trophy surely they fixed
things in this remastered ps4 version
right either way we're going to take
some extra precautions for this trophy
run which means it's time to go over our
Platinum strategy to unlock the Glorious
platinum I'll need to collect 36
trophies and it's estimated to take
around 25 hours step one story here we
play through the game's main story which
consists of 24 levels that take us
through Harry's first four years at
Hogwarts consider this your spoiler
warning for the first four Harry Potter
books completing these should unlock six
Story related trophies that cannot
missed Step 2 replay story visit the
Leaky cauldron
and replay the story missions that's
right every single one of them you see
Lego likes to hide things in their games
that you can't unlock on your first
playthrough then we'll need to collect
all the gold bricks each level has four
of these shiny little objects and there
are 200 in all that's right 200 gold
bricks this is also the step where we'll
want to unlock more characters each
level has three to unlock there are 167
in total that's right 167 characters but
retro he said there are 24 levels and 24
times 3 is 72 so where are the other 95
coming from that takes us to step 3 free
roam this one is mostly about cleaning
up any gold bricks or characters we've
missed we'll need to search Hogwarts and
Diagon Alley to find all the students in
Peril and all of the red bricks actually
we could use cheat codes to unlock a lot
of the red bricks if we wanted to but do
I look like someone who would cheat at
Lego Harry Potter years one through four
must resist control your emotions
discipline your mind step four
challenges here we'll need to finish off
all the miscellaneous trophies that
require specific challenges like
defeating the mountain troll with
stuttering Professor or becoming a ghost
and scaring 20 people like this
foreign and with that plan in place I
grabbed some snacks a nice cold beverage
made sure to give Luna a nice belly rub
because she's such a good dog and then
we kicked off our Platinum Quest it
literally starts exactly how the movie
does
[Music]
the first thing that strikes me after
not playing this game for so many years
is just how nice and crisp the PS4
version looks I'm also reminded of the
authenticity and respect Lego always
show the IP they work with but yet they
still manage to find all the right
moments to inject some classic Lego
humor
[Music]
this is also one of the Lego games that
didn't have any spoken dialogue
everything is conveyed through grunts
hand gestures and the wonderful Lego
animations we've come to know and love
over the years I start knocking out
story missions left and right Harry
learns he's a wizard visits Diagon Alley
and sets off to Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry at about two
hours in something hits me
I've yet to unlock a single trophy I
checked the trophy list again and
realized the majority of these aren't
going to start popping until very late
in the game especially if I'm not going
out of my way to focus on them early so
we get to Hogwarts and let out all of
our trophy frustrations on the castle
around us that's basically what the Lego
games are anyway if you've never played
one destroy stuff build stuff destroy it
again and a few puzzles along the way at
about two and a half hours in we finally
unlocked our first Trophy this one for
collecting ghost studs with that now
under our belt it was time to take our
first classes we had charms with
Flitwick potions with Snape herbology
with Sprout and our first flying lesson
with Madame Hooch Owen this also
happened when we were taking charms
oh my goodness it's boy we already
unlocked him he's the very first
character we unlocked nice to know we've
got that one out of the way after
showing off our excellent flying skills
to get Neville's remember all back
Professor McGonagall recruited us to the
Gryffindor Quidditch team unfortunately
you don't actually get to play Quidditch
in the Lego games but there is a
quidditch level while the game is going
on you play as Ron and Hermione to try
and stop snake from jinxing Harry's
broom of course in reality it wasn't
snake jinxing the broom anyway soon
enough the trio learns it's actually
quarrel who's trying to steal the stone
so they set off to try and stop him the
final level is probably my favorite from
year one you get to sneak past fluffy
destroy a few devil snare plants catch
the winged key and play a Lego game of
chess before heading into the final room
to battle against the professor Coral
version of Voldemort after taking him
out we were awarded with our second
Trophy this one for completing the story
of the first book from there we jump
straight into Chamber of Secrets with
Ron breaking Harry out of his darsely
prison with a flying Ford Anglia once we
arrived at the borough we ran over our
best friend a few times with this giant
pumpkin car sorry Ron gotta get them
trophies despite Dobby's attempts to
keep us away from school we eventually
made our way back to Hogwarts sadly the
confrontation with the Whomping Willow
is just a quick cut scene in this game
we do get a defense against the dark
arts lesson in year two and even though
it's Lockhart teaching we learned the
new immobilist spell which is useful for
taking out Cornish Pixies we Brew
Polyjuice for the first time which is
actually pretty important in this game
as it's how you'll transform into other
characters when you're free roam later
on Harry finds Tom Riddle's Diary and
through her memory learns about his
accusation that it was Hagrid who opened
the Chamber of Secrets hagra tells us to
follow the spiders and after an epic
escape sequence in the Ford Anglia Harry
and Ron find Hermione's note with a
picture of a basilisk it's always so
interesting to see the little tweaks
that Lego makes to tell a much larger
story in a much shorter time frame and
in this case they even do it without
spoken dialogue this is enough
information for Ron and Harry to venture
into the chamber but they bring along
Lockhart for the ride we battle it out
against the giant basilisk and secure
our fourth trophy then it's time for
Prisoner of Azkaban which surprisingly
was my least favorite section of the
game something about the levels here
just felt more tedious and drawn out
than the others we do get Professor
Lupine in this one as well as some fun
winter scenes this is also where we
learn expecto patronum but sadly it's a
non-corporeal version of the spell does
have a really cool sound effect though
we get an actual gameplay section with
the Whomping Willow this time just
before the trio learned Ron's pet rat
was Peter Pettigrew all along and that
Sirius Black is innocent Lupine and
serious at a trap for Pettigrew but
lubin's transformation into a werewolf
gives Pettigrew just the moment he needs
to escape Harry casts expecto patronum
to save his Godfather but that's not
where this game ends there's an
additional level where we need to
actually break Sirius out of his cell
and fend off a bunch of Dementors in the
process another trophy for us and in a
hilarious nod to the end of the Prisoner
of Azkaban film we get this ending I
think Hermione knew what was coming
if prisoner Advanced command was my
least favorite section of the game
Goblet of Fire had to be my favorite
maybe it's because the tri-wizard
tournament has so many sections that are
just great for video games like the
dragon task you also have the underwater
rescue which was so much better than the
movie tie-in game by the way then you
have the maze followed by the graveyard
scene at the very end you also have the
presence of even more characters inside
and around Hogwarts with the durmstrang
and bobaton's visitors along the way
during the story we unlocked a few
additional trophies because Hermione now
knows how to use a Time Turner we were
able to interact with these clocks and
get the back in time trophy we also got
the teacher's pet trophy for completing
all story lessons and quiet please for
turning off all sound while you're in
the library then we got story complete
for finishing the story levels in all
four years and head boy for completing
the year four story levels so with
everything done on the story side Step
One is officially complete and we have
10 out of 36 trophies yeah we got work
to do on to step two where we need to
return to the Leaky cauldron and replay
the story missions on free play all the
while hoping that some of these other
trophies will happen naturally along the
way but in order to do this I first had
to make sure that I had at least one
character who could open locks one
character who can dig one strength
character and one character who can do
dark magic I looked up some guys and
found a few of the easiest characters to
unlock who would fit those criteria I
also went to daikon alley and purchased
some new spells including glacius which
is required for one of the trophies I
bought every red brick that we had
unlocked naturally in our playthrough as
some of these perks will help us with
other trophies then we got the good dog
trophy by defeating 20 enemies with Fang
and chilled out by freezing 20
characters with glacias while replaying
levels from year one there are three
things I wanted to focus on rescuing
students in Peril finding all three
character tokens in each level and
finding all four house crests in each
level and while most of these are fairly
easy to find I found I was almost always
missing one or two by the end which
unfortunately means I had to play a few
of these levels yet again for a third in
some even a fourth time at least it
helped me perfect my path to the
Quidditch level which I needed to
complete in under five minutes to unlock
the quick quidditch trophy all of this
section here was pretty tedious overall
but soon enough I had managed to get the
trophy for Crest collector and then went
straight into year four with it being my
favorite and soon enough we had unlocked
the ultimate collector later I moved on
to year two and unlocked arachnophobic
for defeating 20 spiders with Ron
eventually we found all the house crests
for year two and I powered straight On
Through To year three as well and
because of our red brick multiplier
perks we also finished every level with
the true wizard rank which means now
we're finally ready to move on to step
three free roam this is also when we
really have to start watching out for
glitches and trying to put some of the
most problematic trophies off until
closer to the end we quickly knock out
solid Snape and lumos Salim now the
detector perks on some of these red
bricks actually make it easier to find
gold bricks hidden characters and even
other red bricks even though I was
tempted by the red brick cheats we
actually managed to find all of them
without too much trouble characters in
gold bricks though different story some
of these are incredibly well hidden and
quite a few of them take you to areas of
the castle that you didn't even Explore
in the main story also glitches yeah
it's 65 overall completion my game just
completely hard crashed out of nowhere
at this point I was actually getting
pretty discouraged the hard crash
worried me that something was happening
behind the scenes that was going to ruin
my Pursuit on some of these character
token trophies so I decided to go back
to Diagon Alley and buy all the
characters I've unlocked so far it
actually ends up being much more than I
thought which gives us trophies for
Quidditch team wonderful Weasleys and
animagus with plenty of ghosts unlocked
now I go ahead and take care of the boo
trophy as well then we knock out a big
one by rescuing the last two students in
Peril it was around this time I also
remembered that 10 of the golden bricks
we were missing were actually from the
10 bonus levels which I'd been putting
off to the end even so there were a few
really tricky gold bricks so red bricks
are done characters are done with the
exception of Voldemort and I know
exactly how I have to get Voldemort we
have to get all of the gold bricks so as
long as the golden bricks do not glitch
they were good we're in the clear now at
190 gold bricks in every single
character aside from Voldemort I decided
to do an extra backup of my save file to
the cloud even though my PS5 does this
automatically each night I had made so
much progress this day that I did not
want to risk losing it after the backup
it was time to tackle the bonus levels
almost right away at the start of the
first bonus level we unlocked the
multiplier trophy for getting 10 million
studs in one level the first level was
okay but after these levels got insanely
tedious most of them were a series of
puzzles where even though you know the
solution almost instantly it takes way
too long to actually complete lots of
walking back and forth at a snail's pace
while carrying mandrakes sure maybe it's
a nice bit of replay value for the kids
who just want a little more fun from the
game but for grown men who just want
their platinum trophy these levels were
painful fortunately after about an hour
they were all completed no glitches
which means
and now we've come to the point in the
video where we had to go through one of
the most mind-numbingly painful missions
in the entire game just to unlock
Voldemort you see the Voldemort
character token isn't like the others
you have to complete a special level
access through Borgen and Berks and only
after you have all 200 gold bricks the
premise of the level is actually pretty
cool you take control of voldmort on
October 31st 1981 which fans will
remember is the night Lily and James
Potter died so what do you get to do
with the most powerful dark wizard in
the history of the series
well break things seriously that's the
whole point of the level you run around
this city and while you can crucio or
even AK the Frantic citizens attempting
to flee that's not how you actually
complete the level to complete it you
need to collect one million studs which
would happen in seconds if you could use
the red brick multipliers but here no
multipliers so what this results in is a
mission where you have to spam this
whereabout repeatedly for about 15
minutes straight while waiting for the
studs to surpass the 1 million Mark I
actually thought about offering my two
boys five dollars each to just take
turns spamming the square button
seriously that's the level of
desperation I had at this point honestly
they would have probably enjoyed it but
I did power through on my own and after
what felt like an eternity I had
completed the level to finally unlock Mr
Snake knows himself is also unlocked the
trophy for 100 in the game but
apparently 100 is not enough for the
platinum trophy because there's also a
trophy for completing all of the Lego
builder tutorial levels this one wasn't
nearly as tedious as the bonus levels
though and I'd actually forgotten this
was even a thing at all in this Lego
game you know with the success of so
many games like Roblox Minecraft and
Mario Maker I'm surprised Lego hasn't
lean into this a bit more over the years
now while we've completed a few
challenges along the way we're finally
ready to move to step four and complete
them all we only have four remaining
muggle trouble defeating the object oral
quandary and what according to
PlayStation is the rarest trophy in the
game role reversal I used Uncle Vernon
in the forest to secure us muzzle
trouble quarrel takes out the troll
easily enough we use Voldemort to wreck
quarrel Mort and then it was time for
the final trophy I think this one is
probably the rarest trophy a because it
takes so long to unlock Voldemort but
also B it's actually a little confusing
what you're supposed to do here the
trophy makes it sound as if you'll
somehow take control of Voldemort while
in the graveyard battle with Harry
instead what it actually means is that
you'll want the companion co-op
character to be set as Harry while you
play as Voldemort then with you playing
as the dark lord you take out Harry with
a quick AK if you didn't know Friendly
Fire is most definitely a thing in Lego
games and with that witches and wizards
we officially have our 60th platinum
trophy and with how tedious the grind
was I think it's gonna be a while before
we attempt to do years 5-7 who am I
kidding it's probably gonna be the next
video
[Music]
thank you